uh and bring you breaking news the
official daily covered figures have just
been released
and the uk has today recorded the
highest number of deaths
since march there have been a further 23
511 new cases of covid reported in the
latest 24-hour period
it's the seventh day in a row that cases
have dropped but as i said a
further 131 people have died from covert
19 the highest number since the 17th
of march this year that brings the total
number of people who have died
within 28 days of a positive covert test
that figure now stands at 129
303 our latest figures given for the
vaccination program as well
64 585 first doses of a vaccine have
been given out
and 171 676 people have received a
second dose million people are now
fully vaccinated against covert 19.
uh well let's bring in our correspondent
iva bennett who is in the newsroom now
to talk about those figures um
so either case numbers are falling day
by day
but the number of people going to
hospital going up and the number of
deaths as well
yeah so good news and bad news with
today's lot of figures i'd say
cases as you say falling now for a
seventh day in a row the 23
511 is approximately half the numbers we
were seeing this time a week ago it's
also
way down on the hundred thousand we were
told to expect
uh that we could see in the third wave
but daily case numbers are of course
only one piece of the puzzle
the deaths and hospital admissions are
the other and both of those metrics are
going in the wrong direction
131 deaths recorded within 28 days of a
positive test today is the first time
we've gone over 100 deaths
since march 23rd the highest number
since march 17th so a good three months
ago it's
still very low we should say compared to
the what we're seeing at the height of
the pandemic but still
is a rise nonetheless going in the wrong
direction and weak on week deaths
have now risen by 40 in the last seven
days so quite a significant
increase there um and it means the spike
in cases we had been seeing is death
most certainly starting to trickle
through to death
the same goes for hospital admissions to
945 people admitted on july the 22nd
which is the most recent day we have
data for
again that's way down on what we saw in
the peak of the pandemic but it is still
the highest number of daily covert
admissions
in hospitals since the end of february
and week on week admissions
have been rising uh now by 25
and i think this is why politicians are
still being quite cautious about the
figures in particular regarding the
decline in case numbers with boris
johnson
saying today that we shouldn't be
jumping to conclusions
we shouldn't run away with premature
conclusions about this he said
because of course we're yet to see the
full impact of the latest reopening
which did of course include the
reopening of nightclubs last week